it was just so important to hear you say
that love can be unconditional but
relationships are not yeah we use that
language right like oh I'm gonna this is
unconditional it's like right
no love I do believe can be right you
can have an unconditional love for
someone but we must have conditions in
our relationships right we there must be
right because otherwise
people can say well
I can do anything I want to do not that
most people operate this way right but I
can do anything that I want to and then
you need to choose this relationship
anyway no
no There Are Rules there are
expectations there are agreements spoken
ones ideally right that we have and you
know I can love someone of course but
choose not to be in relationship with
them if they're the way that they show
up the way that they talk to me the way
that they treat me doesn't match with
what is workable for me in that chapter
of my life we've all heard oh love is
unconditional relationships are
unconditional it's like that message was
such a it felt like such a dangerous one
right because it it almost forced people
to
um have to bypass their experiences and
their feelings and be okay or like find
a way to be okay with things and I I
think this is such a healthy way to
exist in the world right that like yeah
to find what the conditions are what I'm
able what what we want to create out of
this relationship together what we are
and listen like it can ebb and flow and
it can move a bit like we can have an
expectation
um if you're in a monogamous
relationship for example that we're not
going to cheat on each other okay right
then that could shift because someone
could cheat and that doesn't mean
necessarily right that that relationship
is going to be over uh immediately right
there's a lot of conversation there's a
lot of navigation that could happen in
that space But I think it's you know we
know we we have to check in with each
other over and over and over again to
make sure that the conditions of our
relationships are up to speed
a lot of times couples for example they
have certain expectations or agreements
for the relationship and then they never
check in with each other for the next
five years or ten years you know and
it's like wait like you're the the
Agreements are changing and we need to
be able to communicate about that and
like not updating your will and having
kids and all kinds of different things
it's like no like obviously things have
changed a lot has happened you've got to
keep that stuff up yeah but I think
there's you know there's an empowerment
in that sentence right it's like love
can be unconditional but relationships
cannot right they have to require that
and there's an empowerment there that
says like I don't have to accept
anything yeah I don't have to just sit
here and be like well because I love you
because we agreed to this like anything
can happen here like I'm allowed to have
conditions to being in this relationship
these are the conditions for us to
succeed as friends as partners as this
as that whatever it is and to not have
to be afraid of communicating that and
sharing that and again of course right
like setting the boundaries around that
yeah it could be called unboundary love
too it feels like another word for it
that could replace it but I like to
think of it as like these conditions or
boundaries or or whatever the word you
want to use for it for the relationship
that's not unconditional is like it's
supposed to help you know how to love me
right like I'm not gonna make it a
freaking mystery I'm gonna tell you what
you have to do this is the key to the
kingdom right if you can if you can live
if this works for you great if it
doesn't fine we all should move on but
that's like unbounded unconditional love
is is not that helpful because it's
impossible to imagine that we don't have
triggers and we don't have wounds and we
don't have things we're working through
and like you said sometimes we're more
sensitive sometimes we're less sensitive
we just don't navigate life like a
Buddha you know we navigate life being
triggered and unless we tell our partner
or the people that are close to us what
those landmines are and what the and
what it makes us comfortable and feel
safe like how can they be expected to do
a good job it's like giving in it's like
giving a pilot an airplane and no lesson
it's like we're gonna crash yeah they're
gonna Crash and Burn you know I think
it's like the conditions are actually
what allows a relationship to thrive
yeah right it's like otherwise it can
just be chaos you know that's that's it
is like no no this isn't meant to like
squeeze something right it's meant to to
create create the environment for
the relationship to evolve and Thrive
um and so yeah I love that one too I'm
glad that was a that was one that stood
out to you yeah those those were the
four most translator and I mean look I I
like have those were literally like I
always write my notes like they are
right at the top and I have like
infinitely more questions I was going to
talk to you about of course some of them
got a little bit included but one of
them that I want to ask about because
this feels a little nuanced but and Miss
like Miss like I don't quite have a
grasp as to how to
see this feel this clearly and execute
this
so maybe you can help me
what does it take to
help someone see you or to see someone
else like people always say and want to
feel seen they want to feel heard like
this is something feels like like a
really deep level maybe not the deepest
level but this is a very deep level that
creates a tremendous connection so is it
something I have to do is it something
someone else has to do is this some
magical connection that you just have to
find the right person and you feel seen
help a girl out help us out yeah I I the
first thing that comes to mind is that
it can be very confronting to see
another
when what is being asked to be seen
requires that person to then see that in
themselves
yeah and it's
that part can be because when one person
is being vulnerable like again we can
listen high level and like yeah okay
thanks for sharing that with me yada
yada right like many people can kind of
go through those motions but I think
when we're talking about being seen
scene you know that like the nuanced
scene
um we are we're talking about uh someone
really deeply connecting to the
experience they're they're being a level
of not that they necessarily walked the
same experiences as you did or
um you know can relate firsthand to that
specific thing but it's there's an
access point that happens when a person
is seen a deep pain within themselves
that then allows them to see a deep pain
within another and I think when a person
is asking
to have a deep pain of theirs seen by a
partner and that and a partner or a
friend or whomever has not has resisted
consciously unconsciously it doesn't
matter but is resisted or not been able
to see their own deep pain that can be
incredibly challenging I think it's one
of the biggest constraints that I notice
and you know because it's like if I have
to connect to it and see it with you
then there's an access point for me and
sometimes people don't want to want to
go there they don't want to go there
they don't know how to go there it feels
too scary to go there it means that the
idealized you know story of their
childhood or their parent or whomever is
going to get you know shifted slightly
right like all of those things can be a
deterrent in that in that way and so a
lot of times right it's like oh to go
into you know intimacy right
um going inwards seeing my inner World
seeing your in a world having you see my
inner world having you see your inner
world right it's like where the blocks
are for the self there are blocks for
others there have to be right because
otherwise it like it requires something
that you're not ready to meet in
yourself and so it doesn't have to be
the same thing are you saying that if
someone has like a a wound where they
have been abandoned in some way or
someone has a wound where they were
abused in some way physically maybe like
whatever that may be does it have to
mirror itself or is it that someone can
empathize because they've been hurt this
amount or this or or like or no it
doesn't in person yeah no it doesn't
have to be the same okay um no not at
all and it doesn't need to be the same
story in the sense of like oh that's the
reason why I can't see you because
that's too close to mine right I think
to me it's much more about right that
level like the connection to
vulnerability that that fear of like
what this is going to open up and so I
can stay surface level with you right
where I'm like think again like I said
like thank you for sharing and I you
know appreciate you so it's like when
someone shares something that's like
makes them cry or like something that
hurts them like makes them feel very
insecure then you go okay here's
something that makes me really emotional
and something that makes me really feel
insecure and then in they don't have to
be the same at all but they invoke the
same emotion like they give you the same
they it's like it's almost like it it's
like an access point to the amount of
your heart that you're willing to show
them and your truth and you go look I'm
gonna I'm bringing in like I'm gonna
bring in two big bags full here you go
and you bring me your bags full and then
you kind of go okay and and that is what
creates the I feel seen is that you're
willing to be that level of vulnerable
with someone because as another thing
that I like to say is you know trust is
a big thing in a relationship and it's
like yeah I want to trust you but if you
don't give me anything to trust how do
you know I'm trustworthy you know like
you have to give someone somebody
something to be trusted with and so you
do that for each other you kind of go
okay I'm gonna meet you there and that
is the I feel seen I feel heard another
reason where that I've seen is when
now an adult
um who was once a child who
um was a was an emotional support or
caretaker for a parent for example
um where they were in a role that they
should not have been in
um and that parent over shared
um they let that child in on very
intimate details of their life their
feelings right like the child was really
just like kind of a long for the ride
and saw a lot of it that is another
example where I can see sometimes a
person be really closed off or shut down
to seeing feeling alongside of partner
for example
um because
of the very
painful experience and exhaustive
experience of being in a role of
caretaking that emotional experience of
a parent and so uh again right sort of
an unre unresolved stuff right but the
unresolved stuff that blocks a person
from being able to actually open
themselves up connect see hear
understand you know be a partner to
someone in the way if we're prioritizing
intimacy and vulnerability right so you
know a lot of this well I guess I would
say all of this would come from
something that's unresolved right like
why why would I not be able to or want
to see you here you'll understand you
connect to you be intimate vulnerable
with you well because there's something
that's unresolved for me whether it's
you know an example like I just gave of
a child who had to be you know the
emotional caregiver
um of a parent to someone who has a part
of their story and their own pain that
they have yet to touch and be able to
resolve themselves if you like this clip
and you want to you want a whole episode
click at the bottom of your screen
[Music]